this one but we do the weapons
to develop targets that's the only
reason we should be doing it
it might give us we might have a lot of
fun
but what you're doing is
some some of you are doing this you're
just replacing your feet
and not going to the side
you're just going
to see that hands to keep them still but
you're just
so you're not going anywhere so it's
like going backwards to go forward
there's no there's no
pen work there in the ken
when we receive we come here and we
i won't say drag but it it gathers
across
so we receive a person's cane
[Music]
and we sweep this across this is where
it comes from
so we gather sorry
that's too much because it it's like in
the world it's been too big our action
but if we go
so this is where this technique comes
it comes here
so it comes from
now the camera can't see my
has one triangle i sweep along the
bottom of the triangle
there's the other triangle
this is not a triangle
circular triangular circular square
okay so please try again